Disney is rebooting home alone and
Macaulay Culkin has something to say
about it you guys give up
oh yeah thirsty for more mac became a
household name after storing as the oh
so lovable booby-trap King Kevin
McCallister in the original 90s
Christmas flick so it's only natural
that he would weigh in on the news and
way and he did in one seriously epic way
on Wednesday the 38 year olds who was
nine when he filmed home alone shared
this pic to Twitter
that's Macaulay sitting on the couch
with a laptop takeout containers video
game controllers and a pack of
cigarettes but the best part is his
outfit a headband unbuttoned flannel
bellied exposing white tank top and gray
boxer briefs the caption this is what an
updated home alone would actually look
like I see you and I feel you Mack in
another tweet the former child star
wrote hey at Disney call me on Tuesday
et reported that the modern version is
set to premiere on Disney's new
streaming service Disney Plus the news
was later confirmed by Disney head Bob
Iger and while Bob didn't share any more
intel on the project including the
release date or its casting he did say
the reimagined version is for a quote
new generation
[Music]
mom dad okay so maybe Mack won't be cast
as the kid again Google had aftershave
to my shopping list but in 2018 he did
bring Kevin back for a Google assistant
ad what Elliott looks like you'll be
animal okay my favorite though is this
moment take a look you want me to clean
these sheets later okay
I'll remind you huh damn we really are
old huh in January et caught up with
Mac's younger brother Kieran
who was also in the flick he played
fuller you know the one who pees the bed
fuller go easy on the Pepsi Kieran told
us that the Culkin family watches the
Christmas classic every holiday season
just like the rest of us it was a movie
for us too growing up which is funny
like you know you would think that
because you know he was in it it was
such a big thing that like we wouldn't
be able to enjoy it like a Christmas
movie but over the years we have been
able to you watch it nobody watch it
okay can you imagine watching home alone
with the Culkin's that literally sounds
like a freaking Christmas dream come
true I'll just be here campaigning for
an invite in the meantime I will be here
to keep you up-to-date on the reboot as
more info comes in so make sure to keep
it locked right here on ET until next
time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now you
filthy animal